normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government we got
this from the Hollywood report we got a
couple stories actually Melissa Barrera
dropped from Scream seven after social
media posts amid Israel Hamas War this
is this is really funny she led both
2022 scream and the sixth installment
released earlier this year and uh she
basically said it's genocide it's ethnic
cleansing Gaza is currently being
treated like a concentration camp spy
glass the company behind uh the scream
franchise had no comments and uh they
gave her the boot we also got this from
sr.com Susan Sarandon dropped by talent
agency for anti-semitic comment she was
get she's getting roasted heavily after
she was at a rally and she made a bunch
of comments Pro Palestinian rally and
then uh I think we have another one here
this one's not as as as as important as
the Hollywood celebrities United Airline
Pilot removed from service over pramas
posts so keeping it you know I wanted to
highlight that in terms of the cancel
culture I don't agree with these people
being fired for having bad opinions I
also don't care I'm not going to come to
their defense and I'm just going to
laugh as the as the door hits their ass
on the way out because too many of these
people absolutely are anti-free speech
too many of these people in New York
these far-left groups have been waging a
war on Free Speech but that being said I
do think we should be careful and maybe
this Melissa Barrera I don't know what
she's all about maybe she believes in
free speech so I'm going to I'm look
into them and if they're in favor of
free speech I'll defend their free
speech if not sorry but what we're
seeing is look the Old Guard is is in is
in freef Fall yeah Hollywood the actors
they're they're split where their talent
are ideologically at odds with their
institutions and I'm not going to sit
here and tell you who's right or who's
wrong we can have a Palestine Israel
discussion later I'm just pointing out
they're starting to fire people the
industry is not doing so well in the
meantime seems like Independent Media is
is is is just skyrocketing I mean a few
years ago if I would have talked about
the sound of Freedom people would not
have believed me if I would have said
there's going to be a new studio they're
going to launch a movie it's going to
defy all expectations crack into the top
of the box office 100 what is that $200
million 250 $250 million people would be
like what dude you can't beat Hollywood
and now Hollywood's dying I mean billion
dollar loss for Disney how you guys
doing is sound of Freedom still in
theaters it is in the world it it is
throughout the world but in the US we
just had the last day in the theaters it
was last Friday or Thursday yeah anyway
it went for like 127 days in the US
theaters it's on my uh it's on Amazon
yes when what new releases is like the
second one right there yeah it was the
in the top 25 most pre-ordered movies of
all time on Apple that's amazing I mean
it is you can really see a shift in uh
focus and groups that once had a very
tight com camaraderie are now splitting
apart there's this poll from Gallop that
came out I think today saying that Biden
has lost 11 points in support in one
month among Democrats among people who
would theoretically be completely behind
him so if you can see it shifting in the
political discourse it's obviously
happening in the cultural discourse
there's going to be Fallout from the
fact that people looking each other and
say I won't I won't even talk to you I
won't work with you I cannot be around
you if you express these opinions that's
crazy I think the kids people that just
see things for what they are are like
the the um diversity for the sake of
diversity it was tried in like 2021
pretty pretty heavily and then it it was
obvious that like if you're not casting
the best person regardless of what they
look like you're you're not making the
best movie I mean looks are somewhat
important but I think Talent se you see
it in the eyeballs yeah the best person
for the character whatever that means so
and now becoming obvious and it's
showing in the budgets like Disney just
launched the worst Marvel movie of all
time right financially and they did
really Po in the movie before that like
let's let's let's think about this it's
a good point the Marvels right it's the
MCU it's got It's got three female leads
and a female villain lead that what was
their budget $300 million I think and it
hits the it hits the opening weekend
with 46.1 million the lowest box office
of all time now I assume it'll make some
money somehow but I kind of feel like
this one's dead in the water it is crazy
to see the Behemoth of the MCU decide to
get woke and then go broke well they uh
was it
the the reviewer um the drunk reviewer
what's his name
drinking I hope his name just the drunk
R that's way better Australian dude what
yeah yeah the drunk and aie movie yeah I
know he's a reviewer I know who I'm talk
sorry I I it doesn't matter what will
figure it out he he was saying that M
that Disney was required by contract to
make critical Drinker yeah critical yeah
critical Drinker they required by
contract to make it this movie yeah that
they they didn't have a choice when they
they they signed an agreement to make
this movie a long time ago and they
tried to wiggle out and they tried to
get out and they were forced basically
through their contracts to finish it out
and he's like and it shows there's no
passion they oh it's the shortest movie
they've done they people are mentioning
that it really looked like they were
just trying to get rid of it yeah
because they had to they had to make it
they signed the agreements on time you
know what I think happened I think uh
early uh this is maybe like eight years
ago man it's been that long like when
they were doing Avengers Infinity War
they needed to get Brie Larson in it
because they were like Captain Marvel
will be the new Iron Man yeah and so she
signed a deal for so many films and then
she appears in a bunch of commercials
everyone despises her she's snoody she's
mean she goes on social media and she
posts really awful nasty stuff and then
they're just like we need to get rid of
her and she's cost him so much money
here's the funny thing cancel culture
right they're firing these actors and
actresses and you know why they're doing
it because they're like we are going to
lose so much money because this woman
went on Twitter and started calling
Israel genocid and all this stuff again
not here to make an argument about
Israel Palestine they're they're they're
looking at how much money they're going
to lose because of it and I get it and
that's that's that's that's a tough
that's a tough issue but understand this
so it was uh just the other day when we
had Danny polishchuk on he made the
excellent joke of as soon as Elon Musk
bought Twitter everybody just went there
are two
genders but hold on like
it's funny because if you really think
about it isn't it absolutely insane that
before Elon acquired Twitter if you said
men are not women you would get banned
no question Megan Murphy she's a writer
in activist she tweeted men aren't women
though she didn't insult anybody they
banned her per for four years she was
banned until finally I think it was
because of yon mus gets brought back we
actually lived in that world where you
could not go on a major social media
platform and say boys are boys and girls
are girls but now where are we what was
happening back then is companies were
genuinely terrified Dave Ruben I don't
think sound of Freedom would have been
as successful as I don't think it would
have hit terminal uh sorry escape
velocity without Twitter they would they
would have suspended you guys in two
seconds they would made up a re we could
we could have brute forced ourselves
maybe to 80 million just through
marketing but the amount that it takes
to get up to 250 million requires you to
hit escape velocity without Twitter
Twitter was the only social platform
where we were trending number one after
it launched over and over and over again
all the rest of them just not there did
you have a plan for Twitter when you
were launching like did you go in
knowing that Twitter was going to be a
resource or was that oranic we we
actually that is why we got into
advertising on Twitter is because now
Elon owned Twitter and we were like we
can actually trust they're not going to
uh mess with mess with this we could see
when we uh were advertising the sound of
Freedom trailer because because of our
advertising career like the number for
for the views and the number of shares
that the videos got and the amount of
activity it just didn't match like
nobody would comment nobody would like
but they were being shared like crazy so
you you you you post your video people
re-sharing it like extremely high rate
super viral trailer on Facebook the
second generation shares have no
comments you can just go through they're
fake so first one no no they're sharing
everybody's sharing it but they're
sharing it into the void right right
they think I'm just sharing the video
I'm excited I shared it and then no one
sees it right no one comments on it and
so the the reshares the second
generation is where the trick happens on
these other social platforms is you you
you you post it and a whole bunch of
people reshare it and you go oh my video
is doing really well but then you go dig
into the reshares and they're not
getting comments they're not getting any
engagement they die I think that
Facebook should alter their advertising
scheme so that if you share an advertise
post it's still going to get advertising
pressure on your reshare yes I agree
with that yeah reshare should should be
promoted so with uh with
X I think I think uh let me go back in
time actually uh I knew these guys that
were investigating advertising systems
on so on on big tech companies and they
were saying at least half of all of the
buys you you purchases are fake when you
when you say I'm put $1,000 in ads
towards this video and then you get
let's say you know 100,000 views 50,000
are fake fabricated and so what Elon
Musk is just Bots they're just Bots yeah
and so this is great for the Mak sense
with the performance before exactly but
here's what happens because it was awful
performance you couldn't it was like
brand marketing on Twitter that the only
way to do it but then Elan mus changes
everything and he says you have to it's
all ads are only going to appear on
verified accounts only count against
verified user views smartest thing and
no one really talks about it it's
working what exactly what Elon Musk is
was saying to the advertisers is listen
if you spend $100,000 on that platform
how do you know you're getting real
people with us on Twitter users only get
ads adds only display against verified
accounts so smart and so the money is
only the money is only spent if verified
individuals with check marks see the ad
so now when you when you when you spend
a th000 bucks and you get 10,000 views
it's so much less so what it's real
people you'll see your conversions go up
yep that's huge thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net